welcome to this video playing a legend
now played him a couple of times already
don't really remember those games let's
see animals oh yeah I played the Queen
see to line recently it's a little bit
more it's a little bit more restrained
yeah compared to them to the craziness
of the same ish huh interesting I never
never looked at this looks like a
transposes to ever goes there
interesting okay from I expected more
something like c5 this just looks like a
Queens gambit exchange where the bishop
is somewhat wrong on before amongst
others also h6 little bit out of place
but of course this is a fairly very
solid position so it's not like I expect
expect to to kill him quickly I'm trying
for this classical pillsbury set up with
f4 may I should have played a 3 before
but okay it's certainly a decent enough
position yeah he wants to trade but if I
go
five some way to play with f5 here but i
don't know if i should really trade
bishop g3 is also interesting
threatening at five
if I go at five here yeah probably the
captures is interesting okay let's do
this it's it's very it's a very messy
kind of position but I was thinking that
this could be interesting on the light
squares take him and then try to play on
the light squares which are really weak
but I have no direct way to do it yeah
probably not steak first one problem is
that I don't go don't get so easily with
the Queen on those light squares yeah
getting the Queen to h5 or something
like that would be excellent it's not
that easy to do okay it's going for this
is an active way to play this looking at
this this is three Pawn okay trying for
Queen to h5 the are Queen to h5 I
definitely have to get as active as
possible an idea now is bishop age for
the Queen has does not have many squares
and the move 95 is probably not very
high on his priority okay shop age for
Queenie five Queen f7 check
twisting
hmm guy is not threatening to take that
very much i have Queen f7 but that's
really tricky position just build up
with rook f3 I don't think he can take
really 995 we should be five Queenie for
Queen f7 shaky King edge aids but I
don't really have a continuation then
problematic
Bishop g6 leads nowhere ship age 425
Queen f7 checking edge I'd already don't
see a continuation after that okay on g6
i will give up the exchange otherwise i
would double on the FR and i keep you
five undercover I think he could take
that I was the first thinking he
couldn't but it seems again so let's try
this and see if he really wants to play
that movie impede so I'm getting this
exchange sacrificing for the spawn and
possibilities of Bishop age for things
like that so oh here it's probably not
really objectively correct but it is
interesting okay piling up here I wonder
ever should play nitey to give this e3
pawn up time morning I don't know he can
maybe play g5 him
could have played g5 it can also just
give a given take only five but it's not
really oh okay
check
wow what a bad game I really don't know
what what did I do wrong there I mean
out of the opening I must have had a
really good position white or exam lost
a couple of Tempe and stuff like that
but I didn't really exploit it this
looks kind of normal but I probably
bungled this up him should have played
something normal and f5 is interesting
or anything it's interesting but maybe
maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm wrong
night a for getting the queen of it
isn't this I mean doesn't shouldn't this
be ok at least I mean have really active
pieces and he has weaknesses on the king
I mean about were serially I really have
you don't don't think so this is
probably bad damn but what should I do
night a form that's what the comp once
did you try to get rid of this this is
really strong bishop this is the comp
line which is may I sent my doubts if he
M can I can actually do Jess it's
actually this win yo check this kind of
idea yeah okay well this is not very
human yeah I thought that yes I should
have some compensation but it didn't
didn't really happen night if was still
good okay yeah and here i mean i didn't
see g5 at all and here I'm I'm totally
falling apart yeah he played this well I
mean the opening really wasn't that
great but it does not seem that I can I
can punish him very severely for that he
is like one or two moves down on a line
that is existing maybe just one move
Bishop before 37 I mean something like
that I can play like this and and I'm
always a little bit better here with the
space and so on but it's nothing when
it's no reputation or anything else
black of legs play
still think this is interesting what
about this then then the then this is
actually nicer the Cessna would square
the code actually wants to play Bishop
f6 yeah giving up the exchange okay well
here I'm clearly better just the
exchange so maybe I should have played
Bishop g60 and this was the key to to
punish them possible and that's very
that's very true ki am inserting this so
that there is no night evade and if he
goes here I'll take here and this is
clearly an improvement over the other
line with the Knights know being
sidelined and there is no defense with
the 911 so quickly i also have a foia
because the bishop is not here if he
tries that i have e 6 and even this move
as possible and this is this is often
the problem here you have a good
position but you need to be super
precise and i simply simply didn't do
this Bishop g6 is much stronger than the
capture Bishop c5 here there was even
this myth which is strongly trading this
bishop when you're five will remain we
can clap then tricky tricky stuff
alright thanks for watching